all right murder mystery we all love a
good murder mystery so do it rockapella
oh yeah i went there you remember
[Music]
so death on the nile is the follow-up to
murder on the orient express once again
directed by kenneth branagh once again
starring him playing the world's
greatest detective ercul poirot did i
say that right sorry comment section
that's gonna have to be close enough for
me pointiest party boat on the nile full
of a lot of people that very well could
have done it it being foul play a murder
takes place now we have ourselves a
murder mystery and what i liked about
this movie kenneth branagh he's just so
good as that character i just find the
character really fascinating i like
characters like him characters that are
so good at their job that they're like
i'm the greatest detective in the world
it's like
you are
you're not just saying that they're a
bit arrogant a bit flashy they like
being the center they like making a big
show of their findings it's like when
you're playing mortal kombat online with
someone and you go up against someone
who's just better than you like doesn't
corner you let you get out of the corner
but still kicks your ass and they do the
teabag thing you know the ducking and
you're like
you were in that tea bag kenneth brown
on this movie earns every proverbial
teabag he gives now this movie has a
packed cast of great actors all of which
do great in their roles i'm not even
gonna talk about specific ones
because in order to keep it objective
what i mean by that is usually in a
murder mystery if you talk about the
ones that stood out that means they had
more to do which means they might very
well be the murderer so to keep it fair
i'm gonna have to either talk about the
entire cast i'm gonna have to talk about
kenneth branagh only they do enough with
the characters keep you guessing you're
guessing like is that a red herring is
it a clue i will give a special
mention to youtube's own russell brandt
who says youtubers can't be in movies i
know he was an actor and now he has a
youtube channel in a world where it used
to be oh youtuber hopes to be an actor
one day now it's actor hopes to be a
youtuber one day my how times change but
i'm glad that i'm doing basically the
end game of actors i just skipped that
step entirely what do you want me to say
i don't know russell i think it would
have been pretty cool if you came on
screen and said hello you 4.8 million
miracles but i digress and the movie
looked great not just cinematography
which it does have really good
cinematography it's appealing it's
smooth gives you a good look i mean
we're on the nile we're in egypt a lot
of cool stuff to see the movie
understands that so yeah you have these
great epic sweeping shots of these
amazing locations cgi of course not as
noticeable as moonfall but you know it
is i still liked it but what i liked
most is the vibrant color and contrast
in this movie something i don't
generally touch on i should more i
totally get that but to be fair most
movies are just kind of muddy looking
whether it be a byproduct of digital
filmmaking naturally looking muddier
than 35 millimeter physical film and
things are shot in digital now so here
we are or it's just kind of what we're
going for like if in the year 2040
they're gonna look back and be like oh
yeah the 20 teens when movies just kind
of had muddy colors because that's what
they were going for probably a mix of
both point is when a movie has colors
that pop these days it really stands out
to me i appreciate it i just find it
appealing now what this movie has to
overcome is a thing that a lot of murder
mysteries have to overcome and that is
hey is it a movie you watch once and
then when you know you know or is it a
movie that has multiple viewing
potential which is pretty par for the
course for a lot of murder mysteries out
there looking at one i think is above
par has re-watchability that'd be the
hateful eight that's not the only one
but i'm gonna address that because that
movie has interesting characters and
great dialogue tarantino's known for is
the dialogue you know so you still have
that dialogue to entertain you as it's
going on death on the nile doesn't
really have that like i said the actors
do a great job in the movie for their
roles but the characters aren't as
interesting
as the mystery is that makes sense and
this does run into a thing that a lot of
murder mysteries these days do
and that kind of compromises the
re-watch ability for me and that is when
you're following along you're not really
following everything because the
detective or whoever's investigating
this thing is seeing things that you're
not saying it's impossible to see the
camera doesn't really focus on certain
things they'll just say like oh by the
way i saw this in the bedroom you're
like i didn't i didn't i don't think i
had the opportunity to see that in the
bedroom so the investigator and the
audience are on really two different
realities going through this whole
situation i like murder mysteries that
take the audience along and it is
possible for the audience to see
everything maybe i'm just spoiled on
murder mystery games because games are
more like that it's kind of hard for a
movie to do that i get it i thought
death on the nile did a better job at
that than murder on the orient express
in fact i thought this movie had better
payoff than murder on the orient express
that is to say i enjoyed this movie more
than murder on the orient express it's a
great looking movie in an interesting
location with enough characters to keep
you guessing i don't see a lot of
re-watchability potential for me this is
a one watch and then it's done and then
you know and then you'll move on to
other movies as you're watching it i
think you'll have a good time no alcohol
required best part about this movie it's
an epic origin story for an epic
mustache that was unexpected if only the
joshua's league could have given us an
epic mustache origin story
we'll never know all right so death on
the nile have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you